i'm often accused of being islamophobic
as are many who
call attention to the reality of jihad
terror
in george orwell's nightmare of a
totalitarian future the novel 1984
a secret police monitors citizens for
so-called thought crimes against the
totalitarian state
a thought crime is an idea or an
attitude the totalitarian rulers deemed
to be
politically incorrect islamophobia which
is generally understood to be
an irrational or pathological hatred of
muslims or islam is the name that has
been given to a modern day thought crime
and a global movement is promoting its
incorporation into law
today in the term islamophobia the
purpose of the suffix is to suggest
that any fear or phobia associated with
islam
for example the calls of its prophet or
its current day imams
to kill infidels or the attacks of 9 11
which implemented those calls
is simply irrational and worse
islamophobia
is a response to those attacks that
reflects a bigotry that itself should be
feared
that's the idea islam however is
different from christianity hinduism
judaism
and most other faiths in that it is a
political religion muslims recognize no
separation between religion and state
and in the canonical texts and teachings
of islam
islam regards all other religions and
non-religions as
infidel creeds moreover islam aspires to
establish a global islamic state
a caliphate that would impose islamic
law on individuals everywhere
and criminalize heretical thoughts
that's where islamophobia comes in
abdul rahman muhammad is a former member
of the international
institute of islamic thought he was
present when the word islamophobia
was created but he now characterizes the
whole concept of islamophobia this way
he says this loathsome term is nothing
more
than a thought-terminating cliche
conceived in the bowels of muslim think
tanks
for the purpose of beating down critics
in short
in its very origins islamophobia was a
term designed as a weapon
to stigmatize and silence anyone who
opposed
jihad terror the organization of islamic
cooperation or oic which is
56 muslim governments worldwide and the
palestinian authority
began a campaign against islamophobia in
2008.
the oic declared its intention to craft
a legal instrument
to fight against the threat to islam
from what they said were
political cartoonists and bigots of
course they were referring to the danish
cartoons of muhammad
that appeared in 2005 touching off
international riots and killings
by muslims worldwide the burning of
embassies the murder of non-muslims
including a catholic nun ekmelodin
isanolu the secretary general of the oic
at that time
said muslims are being targeted by a
campaign of defamation
denigration stereotyping intolerance and
discrimination
note that he was talking about the
cartoons of muhammad not the people who
were killed
over the cartoons of muhammad issan only
went on to say
islamophobia cannot be dealt with only
through cultural activities
but through a robust political
engagement
that engagement would be directed toward
restricting the freedom of speech
abdullahi wade president of senegal at
that time and the oic
chairman explained it this way he said i
don't think freedom of expression should
mean freedom from blasphemy
there can be no freedom without limits
in july 2008 in a briefing on capitol
hill
pakistani embassy representative asma
fatima defended the muslim outrage
as necessary and called for restrictions
on speech that insulted islam
she said the ideal of freedom of speech
is precious to you
but it's not value neutral you don't
have to hurt people's sentiments
and bring them to the point where they
have to react in strange ways
this is the ultimate goal of charges of
islamophobia
to stigmatize demonize marginalize
and ultimately criminalize criticism of
islam
such that jihad terror activities can
continue unimpeded
and unopposed the charge of islamophobia
is a valuable tool
the allies and supporters of jihad
terrorists have to silence the foes
of jihad terror for more information go
to this website
you